[Music]
this week we've got wound call it's a
vibrator and brick backfire yeah so for
our first story it's been announced that
the moon will have cell phone service Oh
as early as next year Wow so I could
busy
for who well I mean there's a purpose
for the astronauts they could [__] them
on Instagram swipe around now they could
do a selfie on the moon so Vodafone and
Nokia have partnered up with this Berlin
based company called P pt scientists PT
scientists and so they're trying to
bring 4G network and live video
streaming to the moon to the moon
thank God I wonder when they gonna do
that and so they're also partnering up
right so that's what this thing is so
funny because so many people are
pointing out like hold on these
companies are focusing on the moon where
there's some rural parts or there's a
lot of rural partners on reception and
[__] Eaton Canyon Pasadena please I
just I just want it in a [__]
elevator like is that too much to ask
for I'm trying to take selfies on the
till we get some reception here that's
right that's true but no no they're
focusing on the moon do you think the
moon is cold looks like a really cold
place safe cold like period I didn't
extremely called yeah he's like deathly
cold I love that you were wondering that
that makes me so happy
aliens need Wi-Fi too I understand it
yes no so the reason why so by the way
they are partnering up with SpaceX and
Audi this will be the first non rowdy a
[__] ugly step-cousin where the [__]
did you come from how are you gonna be
creating two Rovers that will be looking
at the moon that had the hoverboard was
it Audi Lexus no [__] with her where the
[__] did he come from I try to give it
to you I surely hope that they bring
back some moon dirt
the main objective the rover's will be
to inspect NASA's Apollo 17 which was
left behind by astronauts in 1972 so
that's a leader back there yeah oh we're
already [__] up the man I told you
minute [__] I'd be super down to look at
moon dirt can we look at moon dirt here
I do they have it at a museum I want to
snort it I think they take it back and
they examine it and [__] that's what I'm
saying I want to feel moon dirt I want
to feel moon rock moon everything you
sound like a hillbilly hear them stick
the Magnum whack-whack manner me [__]
beta alpha bounce comfortable they're
really good for oh it's really nice
surprises you got shoes on them feet
it's cold these days yeah so let's go
back to this moon dirt so tell me about
that our moon dirt so why people avid
because of that because they're like
okay you guys are focusing on their work
on the moon and having space have better
network coverage and the stupidest [__]
on earth they want to be the first ones
there so that if we ever if you ever
moved to the moon they [__]
monopolize everything this mission will
be instrumental to future missions
though so what I also think they should
add them they shotgun controlling moon -
I think it's super important guys you
build out on me at all aliens humans
nothing why the Nerds focus so hard on
this like next-level [__] when all they
got to do but if we get reception in the
[__] canyons then everybody's gonna
be like wow thanks now if I [__] get
lost on a hiking trip I can call the
cops or some [__] they're doing it on
the moon because they they strike out
every single girl here so they're gonna
try to move over there and try to [__]
some moon beaches what is what if is
just like a like that one character from
the rule for Fantastic Four the rock guy
oh the thing-thing [__] a piece of rock
well it's
oh no no what that guy's dick is like
was it always horribly Rocky is it
always heart disease no right does they
ever go fly meeting it's a good thing if
the guys were hard right what does his
equivalent of erectile dysfunction oh
that's a good question
like cement oh no like a sack of wet
cement there are some soft rocks if you
heard of the lava one crumbles away for
that karaoke uneducated people on earth
I won't make some moon dirt I want me a
moon crown to go with my moonshine and
my moon pies just no what's that soft
little rock co labor homies Thomas
mother [__] Thomas for the [__]
soul it's brittle as fun holy right I
love how its imagine that boning you
that he's exfoliating my vagina how do
we get there from the moon rocks
Oh dick hard
there we go like space became less
interesting as I got older that's cuz
you don't get stoned [__] take a hit
a weed watch some Netflix [__] Neil
deGrasse he talked about space and [__]
you want to get zoned in like a
[__] you want to hear some
[__] [__] though so I like I
haven't been able to sleep very well
right did you finally do it
so I got a bunch of edibles you smoke
the devil's lettuce No so I the moment I
get it
[Laughter]
you smoke the devil's below any elm I
did now so we got a but I got a bunch of
edibles right some medical-grade edibles
was like cool I was like well I'll
probably take it tomorrow night
so I knock out right super earlier okay
cool I'll take it tonight oh is that
like [__] two huge like bags of like
edibles out of me
I think sleeping so you just have it
there and the thought of it just makes
you know it's like some kind of placebo
effect I don't know what the [__] it is
but it's in the fridge and I miss
sleeping like at 1:00 a.m.
12:30 2 a.m. which is your weight
earlier your body's more scared to take
it so just go to sleep David go to sleep
I'm never gonna do his like my [__]
body she's doing this to me go to sleep
[__] and I try some I never had
edibles before yeah I'm scared of
edibles I know it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be really really strong so I
just try a little quarter one of them's
a chocolate one of the butter like
brownies so the cubed butter what do you
put in your mouth and milk you meet you
put it on food you just my friend used
to do that he would boil the butter with
the weed and then he would extract it
and then resize it into a cube and he
would make cookies with that all kinds
of [__] by the way I sound like a STONER
but I probably smoked like once every
three months just to put it out there
I think I'm doing I'm gonna I'm gonna
get the pins I've notice leap at night
too I been sleeping early it's just like
one of those things it's like if I just
pop a kid and I good be lazy about it
it's so damn important you know what I
mean like ever since I've been able to
sleep my mind's like 10 times more shot
yeah I wake it up at six of the ball or
about alright for our next story uh you
guys remember how we talked about
I'm sorting in the moon rocks yeah so
cam soda the adults entertainment
website candy soda cam okay okay I'm up
I'm up am them I knew what that is again
like girls like what are the clothes
yeah yeah cam girl website so they are
releasing a vibrator called rub grub
whoo oh that's interesting
that's clever and so it has a feature on
this vibrator that if you press a button
it will order a large tooth pizza from
dominos for you how is it how is it
related
is it possible to marry an inanimate
object yes cuz I'm down dude that's the
one you like yeah no I'm good oh so you
like that it vibrates and orders people
soon
you know my favorite dildo video is the
girl who had a dent in her car and then
she put the fat black dildo on it and
then she popped it up she's like this
who's dead in her car and they she took
the the suction side of a huge black
build oh my god Joel business idea in
Vegas she was such a tiny little girl
too and I think was Chinese
yeah don't remove its hire a bunch of
hot [__] and bikinis and just having
this one Instagram page that all they do
it's like these guys a creep he's really
detailed scene and then somewhere in
that scene they're hiding this huge
dildo you have to find it like it's like
Where's Waldo where's go with your idea
that that whole thing gets filmed but
then in slow-mo so they could buy the
the dent coming out and they're like oh
okay
[__] top corner in or if you want to
pay for the rated X videos
she puts a dildo in her squeezes real
hard and pulls it out that's a really
strong people do
[Music]
to invest and then you went there and I
go way back no don't make more money you
nerd ready well yeah I mean if it's a
porno you kind of need that part so she
obviously has to suck off the dildo and
then gravity no it wasn't a porno it was
an actual service oh it's still a
service service yeah she's gonna service
the dildo and then you do the service
half so it's like you pop the dildo in
and you go Oh suck it out suck the dent
out but the prices are like lowest
prices by hand she's yanked it out and
then another like tier two as a mouth in
two or three years and then tier 4 is a
bottle doesn't have a lot of like
strength right I think you could crunch
harder with the butthole then you can't
with a vagina hole okay oh yeah my balls
paste wrong you need that I thought it
was just wrong at the ring but the
outside bowels don't have any oh it's
the ring used to ring yeah yeah yeah
it's the ring a fire that's what you
used to [__] cut off the Dookie it's
the pizza yeah it's the [__] cigar
[Laughter]
[Music]
build an eon take a muse marcus you come
up with the craziest ideas you're a
great business woman I'm a great
business woman I just never put it into
action because you're an inventor so
you're an inventor you need you need
someone to build it out for you
trademark Dilbeck don't you [__]
steal I should do that yeah you connect
the vibrator via bluetooth and then you
add your billing info and like whatever
pizza you want and it was so funny
because Domino's is like why not first
that we've heard of that so why only
Domino's well they are saying that they
do want to expand some Mexican and
Chinese cookie dough be awesome give a
Panda Express but not that's kind of
like the beginning of a porno though
like if Pizza Hut was smart
they have to cut holes in it and then
the girl open they open the boxes after
you have sex what do you prefer Chinese
Mexican or pizza yeah they'll be
fantastic I'm gonna give you a massage
it reads you a bedtime story something
like that or someone that like plays it
funny usually it's like it's like the
stereotype is the guy that takes to
sleep at they're so active after they
get funked you're just like what the man
cuddle for a second dude he's a lover
don't touch me
just called us [__] right now it's funny
when you bone yeah I guess just use the
AC or something David's a missionary
kind of man we get it no I'm not a
missionary kind of man I just lay there
and see what happens baby you want some
yeah yeah you know what's gonna go you
know what's happening tonight don't you
position one she's just slapping anyway
wait wake up wake up
I for last story and there was this hair
would be crooks in China Chinese cooks
are the best
[Music]
[Laughter]
copy
what the [__] do you know she is not a
true homie I got no friends I drank this
within an hour and almost had a heart
attack during JK news I thought I was
gonna pass out and die David I drank one
of those when I went to go get a tattoo
with my dad cuz I didn't know any better
at the time and I'll sit in this like
halfway through the halfway through
attencion like falling asleep because I
crashed that shit's so strong yeah my
[__] C return on my Apple watch and it
couldn't read what the [__] [__] and it
responded but but I'm not talking to you
[__] would be crud in China
I'm not even gonna tell you what happens
and you already know what happened but
it's so good so here we go I got don't
steal that's what's on their minds yeah
I like to steal I steal I like the I
steal I like
[Music]
that fools brick didn't go straight it
went that way you know what the funny
[__] about that is it's like people
people think when people are knocked out
they have like a specific set of what
happens right this fool is literally
knocked out stupid legs or so you see
like in the USC did when people get
knocked out it's so funny when they get
knocked out stiff and they're just like
this hilarious conversation they're
gonna have when he wakes up that's gonna
be so awkward just be real with you okay
this is what happened you throw the big
bounce in your face I don't know who oh
[__] that [__] is crazy
dragging his friend away like he's a
Jeremy's not leaving him behind
oh I would have ran away i legit what a
rat away right you're a so you have to
take he's not gonna happen
exactly you don't really remember [__]
like you don't really remember what
happened like the few moments right
before your memory like that short-term
memory is gone it semester remaining
slowly comes back and then you're like
oh wait no one tells you it's like it
never happened
that's well you know on the people you
get knocked out in the UFC there's still
that grappling with the ref and then
they're always explained you lost you
[__] lost look look well you know you
[__] lost like they don't even know
what happened even though they five
years because when something like that
traumatic happens but what happened is I
would run away and they would wake up
and then like what the [__] happened why
weren't you there like what the [__] I'd
have been like bro I never went with you
in the first place
[Laughter]
the walk was too hot I don't know like
their because they didn't take anything
and so I'm not sure you're caused any
damage they don't really report whether
or not they come well they left our
dignity so that's hilarious they
definitely lost in that war I wouldn't
use that I would use if I was a company
that installed the glass windows to that
building I would use as an advertisement
whatever store they're trying to rob I
would take that CCTV and put it on a
digital TV and then play it over and
over and over so everybody can laugh all
right that's a good advertisement for
security cameras too like big wall the
big screen record yeah yeah one for the
bridge there you go there's that video
that guy trying to throw the brick into
the glass and it bounced back
and that's one of the classics I love
watching videos of like burglars that
get in big trouble
like there's this one that goes into a
jury shop and then the doors closed on
them and then the gates fall down and
they're trying to smash through and they
can't let me out blue you know what was
harder than I thought
breaking a glass bottle it's not as easy
like in the movies you know how they do
it just very like back and it breaks you
got to put some little yeah you have to
aim or something I don't know about that
but you know like I was younger I just
[__] around cuz I saw it on TV so
much I went and then it just made like a
little [__] and burn all my friends
what the [__] I never broke it on a
table by broken on someone's head before
alright a real one and if you are if you
hit hard
it's like shatters like it's tissue
thanks I remember when you guys are
filming that skit and we had those sugar
bottles and I got down and like this
little rumble in Temple City beckoned
eight and then uh I smashed over his
guy's head and it just shattered like
all talking about it's not a beer bottle
leave the romani bottles oh dude there
are a lot thicker than their lot think
of the beer bottles see you not a [__]
okay so thank you hey you know those
that want to get the marble from it the
sugar models do they taste sweet when
you like them you guys didn't try it
that's not the first thing we did I
think we did eat it I think we did and
it was weird Haley because I'm the first
thing I did yeah it does it's not this
week is this it they they put like a dye
like the chemical dyes yeah so it's not
like sugar sugar
[Music]